das auch ein kindergeburtstag ciao ciao
also
die torte hochzog kaum aufwand einfach
ist manchmal eine schoko creme im
hintergrund dieser muss ich ja
[Musik]
hallo zusammen heute gibt es mal einen
graffiti kette richtig lust darauf den
zu machen ich habe er jahrelang mal so
gesehen und dachte mir so auch cool das
sieht so aus als würde die ems packung
schweben und entließen sie auf den
kuchen ich hatte einfach lust es selber
zu machen ich zeige euch heute die
schritt-für-schritt-anleitung ich habe
dafür zuerst meinem fluffigen vanille
bizkit boden gebacken und genau für
solche fälle gibt es ja mein extra video
dafür einfach auf den link in der
infobox klicken da findet ihr alle ganz
genauen anleitungen also so schritt für
schritt anleitung ich habe allerdings
das halbe rezept genommen auch dazu
gibt's alle infos in der infobox und
natürlich alle anderen zutaten die ich
hier benutze also das ist wie gesagt
vorbereitet darum kümmern wir uns gleich
wurden uns jetzt kümmern müssen ist
einmal die leckere schokocreme dafür
einfach samel in einem topf erwärmen
nicht hochkochen das ist ganz wichtig
nur erwärmen und dann schokolade dazu
geben ich nehme hier diese edelbitter
schokolade mit 70 prozent kakaoanteil
ihr könnt aber auch eine 60-prozentige
nehmen können auch freue mich nehmen
also der seite komplett variabel
ich habe jetzt die schoko sahne mischung
einmal in eine rührschüssel gegebenen
gleichwertig doch noch an der maschine
auf stein ihr könnt aber auch euren
druck gerät benutzen und ihr seht schon
das ist schon sehr flüssig also so
können wir natürlich nicht weiter daher
könnt ihr das am besten auch schon
vorbereiten und richtig schön auskühlen
lassen im kühlschrank und dann zeige ich
euch das wird richtig schön fest und das
brauchen wir jetzt aber erstmal für
unseren gravity effekt tut das mal kurz
zur seite und da man eigentlich einen
plastik stroheim ich habe jetzt nur glas
stroh heimat und dann gebe ich auch
gleich noch hier zum stabilisieren einen
schaschlikspieß da rein und noch einen
zweiten weil mir der so ein bisschen zu
kurz wäre das könnt ihr dann einfach
abhängig machen von der höhe ihrer
tochter aber das seht ihr dann gleich
wenn ich das dann rein stecke dahin
nämlich noch einen zweiten schacht spies
hat man so ein bisschen in kürze einfach
abgerissen mit den fingern und gibt ihn
noch dazu so und das ist quasi unser
gravity modell und da gehe ich jetzt so
ein bisschen
für mich auch wie sind die
wissenschaftlerin gerade auf jeden fall
scheiße ich jetzt hier so diese
schokomesse drauf und dann werden
einfach nur die modems trip oder man
nimmt ihr könnt auch gerne hier diese
kaufland you can also ich habe mir nur
gedacht das ist halt so typisch bekannt
mit m&ms die schmecken mindestens
genauso lecker oder ihr leben hier diese
ortlieb ich ja über alles nur diese
schoko sieht einmal eine packung auch
schmeckt die alle alleine weg hauptsache
das was ihr verwendet ist nicht so
schwer das sollte schon ein bisschen
leichter sein soll ich erledige das hier
mal und dann machen wir gleich weiter
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt die creme wie gesagt
einfach nur noch immer aufgelockert das
hat jetzt auch nur zehn sekunden in der
maschine gedauert mit dem handrührgerät
müsst ihr euch auch nach 10 15 sekunden
schauen dass sie dann nicht gruselig
wird das ist etwas endergebnis ich werde
jetzt meinen vanille biscuit schön
durchschneiden und dann das ganze
einfach nur schichten ich habe mich mit
meinen geschmack einfach für schoko
vanille entschieden für mich jetzt ganz
schön ganz klassisch jeder markt und
genau nach dem schichten geht es dann
weiter
[Musik]
also man könnte eigentlich meinen dass
es schon eine fertige torte arbeitskampf
noch viel mehr ich habe jetzt oben
drüber noch mit einem torten kann so ein
bisschen dekoration gemacht und baccara
obendrüber gegeben ist einfach hübscher
finde natürlich wird gleich ein teil
davon durch die m&s überflutet aber
trotzdem wolltest ja von oben nach einer
schönen fertigen torte aussehen so und
jetzt kommt's an den rand quasi weil ich
hier noch ein bisschen was an deck oder
habe ich hier diese knusper regel und da
wir die ein bisschen zu lang sind werde
ich sie jetzt auch einfach nochmal in
der hälfte durchschneiden und durch die
creme klebt es dann automatisch fest und
dann kommt eigentlich nur noch unsere m
& m es dazu
[Musik]
die torte sieht ja schon echt cool auf
also ich muss auch sagen sie ist
anfänger geeignet auch wenn man
vielleicht im ersten moment den bauhof
es ist das wie wahnsinnig aufwendig ihr
habt ihr gesehen einfach nur den
strohhalm reintun dann dm und ems runter
laufen lassen ja bist du nur einfach
hingelegt die vorne können wir so ein
bisschen im creme drücken gleich wenig
oder wenn ihr das spiel serviert auf dem
geburtstagstisch oder so könnt ihr hier
noch überall ein bisschen machen die
sonst auf dem boden laufen das sieht ja
echt cool auf und geht auch wirklich
sehr sehr schnell und um das jetzt noch
mal hier zu befestigen nimmt euch
einfach die leere tüte und dann braucht
ihr noch einen schaschlikspieß dann habe
ich einfach mit den händen so geknickt
dass es nicht ganz durchbricht und so
ein bisschen gekürzt und dann legte das
hier oben rein und dann kommt die leere
tüte können wir ein bisschen auf holz
dann hieß aber nichts drin einfach nur
oben drüber
also man muss gucken wie man sie dann
drapiert das sorgt für strahlende augen
oder ich bin auf hansas ich will richtig
haben das reaktion gespannt das ist die
fertige torte und wir sehen uns welche
und texter ist
[Musik]
denn auch zu haben dass sie an künftig
also
entweder den blick ist so höher ist das
denn oder
ich finde das ist also das auf dem
kindergeburtstag ciao ciao ich habe
schon vor 50 jahren mal gesehen ich hab
mich immer gefragt wie machen sie das
jetzt täglich genauso und hat sich bei
den zu machen wolltest immer machen es
ist einfach ein stück noch heute gerne
den erfolg dass du ein über ein stück
also wohl kein schokokuchen ich sag ja
es muss nicht immer 1000 schichten und
1000 geschmäcker und so einfach ist
manchmal die schokocreme ismeca gilt die
so was muss ich als sonnig dass er
dieser software analyssuite wurden das
macht seit 17 jahren mein gott rezept
sofort haben habe ich dagegen diesem
rezept aber ich finde es gut das hat so
ein guter charakter wie sie klingt ja
weil ich die aufgeschlagen hat sich anna
und der wieder aufgeschlagen schmidt gut
also dass wir noch auf hilfe erwachsener
und das ist echt was für wände auf einem
kindergeburtstag kind sein aber es ist
ja eigentlich nicht auch geguckt mal ist
mir auch entweder möglich nur die kinder
und die erwachsenen würdest du würdest
du punkte vergangen machen muss ich die
punkte vier wochen würde ich mich doch
mal freuen da will ich ganz ehrlich
sagen ich könnte mich richtig richtig
gedacht ich würde schon achteinhalb von
single stabil achteinhalb von 10 acht
von zehn bin ich sehr zufrieden mit die
torten hochzog kaum aufwand wirklich du
denkst du wolltest zehn jahren küche ist
unrecht also mit filmen dauert immer
nicht länger ohne zu finden drei stunden
damit könnte dazu anders machen du
kannst auch töten smart ist klar und
alles hier malteser es geht auch ich
habe jetzt mein vorschlag wenn jetzt die
community wir auch so of interest oder
solche torten side bestimmten sieht
scheint man jetzt in die kommentare
beschreibt wie ich passte mir schon was
zusammen und dann mache ich direkt nach
das tut mir so viel spaß machen
abonnieren und pries meine freunde die
beamten zu
[Musik]